i'm stefan hell mike i'm the convener of
the invisible panel along with my co
convener rebecca you chill and the title
of this panel might as well be or also
be seeing material how do we see
material things whoever we are how do we
see material things when technologies of
cloaking and of machine vision change
the material capacities and
possibilities of seeing of who and what
can see what when what does it mean to
be visible or invisible visible and
invisible so think too of the material
networks of monitoring surveillance and
data capture that help or hinder
governmental or citizen seeing or
undocumented seeing in our digitally
mediated days think of this to material
things bear the traces of their
conditions of production and circulation
and such traces may be made visible or
invisible as carbon footprints or
offsets as reclaimed landscapes or as
brownfields as renewable energy or toxic
wastes and this panel invisible is about
all of this we will be seeing and
hearing from George Barbra stassi's
professor of mechanical engineering at
MIT
George is known for creating an optical
invisibility cloak a calcite crystal
system that may make it possible to hide
objects in plain sight we'll be hearing
from Trevor Paglen an artist and
geographer who explored and documents
invisible infrastructures ranging from
secret corporate and government sites to
orbital atmospheric landed and
underwater networks known through
technologies of non-human machine vision
Trevor's presentation will take the form
of a
conversation with Lisa parks Lisa parks
is a professor of comparative Media
Studies here at MIT parks writes on
television satellites drones and
infrastructures of surveillance the PAS
Glenn parks conversation will then be
followed by a presentation by Michelle
Murphy professor of history and Women
and Gender Studies at the University of
Toronto Murphy is a historian of science
who studies often invisible the
ecological infrastructures tracking for
example the way environmental toxins are
made visible or invisible and her latest
work has been dedicated to rescuing
scientific data about climate change as
we risk losing it under climate change
denying governance and the last of our
panelists but also the first since since
she is our moderator is sandy Alexander
Alexander writes on black American
material culture particularly literature
and photographs and she examines how
histories of black displacement
invisibility and vulnerability haunt and
energize the way that black lives matter
now so I'm going to hand the
conversation over to sandy who will
provide framing thoughts to launch the
discussion of being and seeing material
in the age of cloaking machine vision
surveillance data erasure and new
techniques of making visible and
invisible sandy
you